welcome to this welcome to this video a
15 minute game playing coldfinger cool
phenomenon Goldfinger their name will
avoid set all of all set from from
Norway so I'm nims oh i should i do
something else I play the Newman so very
often the slide check with some okies
going further the logo my opening um
ciao still have this drilling here it's
driving me insane let's just stop it but
now side again it really a is not
helping and making any videos tell you
that ok after be 6a White's main move as
a three but you can also play it in this
somewhat restrained fashion III Bishop
e3 and sort of ask like what is your
bishop doing on reform are you going to
take any way or are you going to retreat
it very often black gown will take on d
to anyway even though without white
having played a three so this sum is not
a bad system for for white black is not
in any trouble of course but it's a good
alternative to 25 a-3 okay
okay so cancelled snow yeah and now why
does some actually threatening or
something threatening III for here
grabbing the center so black gum must do
something yeah this is one of the
possible moves and here am I going to
take and play 95 it's not in not bad
maybe take 95 f for this kind of setup
or be three yeah I can also play be
three it's not bad a three I don't like
so much looks like a bit of a loss of
tempo
oh this is a strange move really and
okay it it is strange because it it
gives up the center in a way I'll I'm
able to play you form the only question
is when when do I do that and he's got
problems to play C 5 SC 5 is always
answered by a 3 which makes them give up
the bishop which is not really what he
wants now i also have quincy to
sometimes getting a temple yeah what
what is them the the way to go here I'd
like to play a form that I'm not sure
about night f4 it's not really if it's
not really great on therefore it must
retreat later but still I would prefer
not to allow that it could be it would
be quite nice if I would move the night
on c4 this could could be an idea so
that after see 583 the bishops almost
wrapped and it allows us to play you for
while still controlling their foursquare
I'm not sure though we had to put it on
c4 maybe maybe on see form okay let's do
that I thought quite a long time about
it already
yeah well I'm always believed that it
makes some sense to spend at least a
minimum of time on the opening move so I
mean those kind of moves are they they
will get to you later I mean if you put
some effort in the the first couple of
moves you often is your game
considerably sometimes people play so
quickly in the opening and then there
are lost like like ten moves after 10 or
15 moves and I always wonder what what
the heck are they doing why not spend at
least a bit of time and the writer being
lost already but I don't know it is very
popular to just dash out any sort of
crap quickly okay what is he doing here
actually nitey 783 I'm trapping the
bishop right but should be 65 as a
bishop trap and if he goes Knight f6 and
I playi 595 am I not able to sacrifice
on HSN this is one of those cases I
believe I mean if I this is good anyway
and I don't see what he's doing now he
cannot go to a forum for example yeah
what about this now the the very well
known Greek gift sacrifice Bishop h7
isn't this just just killing yeah yeah I
don't check I don't really see why it
shouldn't be neither six I can go on IDF
six actually this is in fact some sort
of a defense
ircam does this that's true that's true
and this damn drill yeah I believe a
book okay so he's got one he's got a
defense some sort of a defense queen age
five Knight to f6 this is this is this
is indeed still playable let's let's
still consider is Queen h5 the right
move there's also Queen d3 for example
it's also quite interesting the big
difference is in relation to Knight f6
now after Queen H 596 is actually
winning winning a tempo
hmm if I go Queen d3 Knight f6 is there
anything great that I can do I don't see
it yeah the queen is not badly placed
here anyway if he goes Knight f6 I don't
take I take a play Queen edge for of
course you cannot move the night anyway
and but the question is listen idea to
Kim well let's not make good science out
of it Queen age three sometimes it could
be an idea to go to h3 but this is ok he
cannot move the night here anyway so it
makes sense not to take it immediately
ok let's see is does he have a dramatic
move like Knight takes d5 I don't think
so now I can just take what the night so
what what is my goal here I would love
to to some are really get to h7n mate em
like it would be nice for example Bishop
f4 takes on f6 Knight f6 Bishop b5 take
on f6 Queen edge 7mate this is very
basic way to to do it ok well you're not
he's still not threatening to move the
night this is not it's not clear what
this is accomplishing if I take it
Knight takes what I don't like is off
about that what I don't like is that
maybe there is a move like Queen d5 wait
wait wait wait if i take night x can I
go nite III intending night g-form this
this is an interesting idea
and it prevents 3d five I can also of
course go to e5 which has some merit but
then queen d 5 as a possible move or I
can I can still delay everything here
and start with a move like Bishop to f4
yeah what exactly is this idea you can
play will create may be trying to
recapture with the bishop
this is one one advantage of taking with
the pawn it in a way it forces him to
turn to play Knight takes
hmm not clear at least for me it's not
not clear I can also do something else I
mean I can just try to swing the rook to
h3 it's not not so clear what he's doing
against that even rook e8 is not helping
him much maybe I maybe just do that
rookie 3h three don't really see a
defense against that to be honest night
xe5 maybe this this could could be a an
idea if I take with the porn queen d 5
yeah but it's not it's not really
helping him much you could try a move
like g6 here maybe 36 and tending queer
night h5 I can play Queen h6 then this
could be the answer
Queen age 6 rook e8 and then there are
multiple ways two things to consider 96
for example very tricky to defend
yeah maybe rupee aid I'll go I go now
I'll go rookie error okay three
then-rookie 383 this is very crude but
it's also quite effective I believe
yeah this was a funny version of the
breed gift I I really played this a bit
too quickly check check under estimating
Knight f6 but ok so g6 um ok night h5 is
the threat yeah I need to do I need to
play this move there is no way around it
really
yeah now I have the additional idea to
play night e 6 as I mentioned just a
minute ago breaking through this pawn
barrier not sure that it's winning or
anything but it's an additional idea
yeah is he going to play rook e8 now
maybe if I take then on f6 you must play
Knight takes and then nitey six maybe
I'll 96's Bishop f8 the back rank takes
Knight x96 Bishop f8 double ! Wow okay
so this is not really working it's there
something else hmm yeah there probably
is bro more than one way to get a good
attack yeah but so there really a
winsome well take nine takes the night
f7 could be a could be a move a 95
actually oh this is I think this is
goose is winning out isn't it Knight
takes Knight f7 threatening no
threatening Queen g6 check and if he
takes 95 this is just a mate made in a
couple of moves yeah okay that that's
that should seal it I don't really see
what he's doing now I'm threatening
Queen g6 Bishop h6 checkmate
and okay the queen is also hanging this
is sorry yeah this is even I just forgot
about that the queen is also hanging so
then that's that's a total killer yeah
96 Bishop f8 was a fantastic defense
check yeah that's made in to check my
def seven made or Queen f7 made black
resigns yeah then Bishop Bishop f7 is
probably good but he maybe has some
defense I don't I don't I don't know
let's let's have a look that's so let's
have a look what happens 95 computer
does not want to take it plays Knight g5
and just yeah okay it's also a very
strong attack ramp I understand check
maybe it's a it's better even check and
now it wants to play Queen d3 but I
don't think that this should be bad
ready because it's a it is a strong
attack in any case so what is the
computers d fancy a bishop a success
what stockfish is giving him this was
his move and this seems to win for white
okay you should a 6
yeah wants to wants to get rid of this
this is night okay I probably cannot
play anything super aggressive here like
that right going for Nigeria this was
the idea ah he's got Bishop here okay I
know I know I understand no a scent so
this this makes this whole idea useless
if I must recapture okay so i must play
this one and now the computer wants to
do that and jump not not so sure what it
is doing
yeah it takes some time this is a this
is a question of of calculation
calculation depth of the computer now it
has some seconds 20 seconds 30 seconds
and it it gets deeper into the position
and recognizes that the tech is very
strong at first it gives us as equal but
if you give it here like 40 seconds it's
getting higher and higher with the move
Bishop f4 this of course I didn't see
any of it in the game now but it's just
just like the typical case where the
computer needs some time to evaluate the
position probably now it sees that after
the capture I just recapture and now
White has this attacking idea to take
and play 95a Bishop b5 something like
that and this is just immensely strong
the computer is not recognizing how
difficult this is the human is quite
quickly seeing that it's very tough to
get out of this year you can never play
King f8 because of Queen h8 you can
never move the night so you are really
in some sort of box here and white is
just attacking with this and f4 f5
another computer is climbing two plus
two plus three and socials that wide
wins it takes so with modern hardware
and a good engine it takes a while for
it to to recognize how tricky the
situation is so this means that white is
getting a tough attack or a difficult
attack to parry anyway so on maybe
Bishop h7 then is still a pretty good
move maybe 95 is better but okay let's
see what happened here the computer
wants to play Bishop e3 which I don't
really understand well it connects rooks
cell and add some stability was this a
bad move I cannot believe it really
rupee one looks quite quite normal it
wants to play c5 now okay
if I do this very crude rookie three
that's 95 okay yeah that's a strong
defense okay and see this is a very good
defense completely stopping everything
okay so then this is probably the
argument against my bishop my rookie one
move I can play an i can just continue
of course it's not like I'm not obliged
to play rookie three Bishop f4 for
example the computer also it's a
suspicion therefore is quite good yeah
it takes a while for the engine to
recognize how strong the attackers it's
simply it's simply a it's simply a bit
deep as it's often better to not capture
but capture later it's still a dangerous
attack here with Bishop f4 but rookie
one was then probably not too precise
this is what you played and this is
winning a queen age 6 plus 9 a.m. okay
it's pretty devastating rupee aid and
exactly my line is winning it is still
funny that this is a cute trap very nice
um it turns out that i didn't i didn't
calculate this any further back this is
still a playable line for white of
course I'm a porn up even but ok this is
a moot point as I can just take here and
win the game okay so basically g6 is is
losing it and I think he only has he
only has the c5 move rookie 8 is the
other move that you could consider but
there's even taking here and 95 as a
possible way to continue I thought that
group III is also strong but 9 f8 really
okay okay Brooke h3a sea route h3 III
okay well Luke h3 is not winning because
of
oops this move and if I take it he's got
queen d 5 this is quite okay maybe it's
got this move known this is why it is so
terrible to play against the computer
I'm a human this is very this under so
much pressure it's very hard to find the
the only defense while the computer will
find it and set so much problems I
probably would have lost this game
against the computer because I would
have found lost in in the Mesa rocky
adium takes Knight takes and 95 is given
as very good for wide yeah okay rook e8
is just neglecting the f7 square the the
funny point is that after this Queen
move y term has the somewhat strange
move rookie form i will FC f3 is also
possible table what I'm getting at is
now now black probably needs to go back
here and then you have this funny move
intending rock rook f4 and taking quite
quite nice also a very strong attack
okay that was an interesting game
instead of this it seems though that 95
was was stronger the ideas that will g6
um there is Queen g4 or maybe just the
sacrifice it's both very dangerous Queen
g4 though is is very strong just
intending to attack without sacrificing
anything very hard to defend and after
if you go here check something like that
is the problem intending queen d 3 or
queen h5 of course you cannot take
without a key because of made in two
moves and this is just a strong attack
without any sort of sacrifice which
makes a bishop h7 probably
are questionable it's tempting but 95 is
just stronger okay thanks for watching